man I tried with so much everywhere I go
I'll take a lot of stuff with me I'd
take a little stuff like these little
cookies from Starbucks I got him right
now and me eat some rose after this
interview hey what's up everybody's a
buddy with the hoodie and uses my
essentials my first reception was right
here man
Madeline's from Starbucks this is my
favorites back of all the times I Vienna
Airport sometimes and I run by Starbucks
and we could be late for our flight and
I need damn I just be stopping at
Starbucks like 90-some Madeline's I
found these by just a strong I like
exploring around a lot I'm a city boy so
I like just walking around the city
going into these little crazy buildings
more like just figuring out where things
are a year to ago I just started going
to Starbucks I ain't never been to
Starbucks my whole life I don't even
drink coffee coffee tastes like I don't
want to talk about coffee
that's it is horrible next we got my
Louie boats
I always keep my Latin but today I got
to leave ocean and I'm running white was
that out to Burns's to new collection
and I got one in black
I will black a lot my main color be
black so always got to keep a black bear
with me it's my favorite random monogram
I'm from New York where swag originated
we rap originated for everything
originated you know you asked me that
question about no fake nothing you can't
go about no fake nothing we do from
harbors speak in the fashion of a
nightmare the flag I got some of my
accessories on me right now I got my me
go for this one I'm sure that's a maybe
shout out to the clothed plugin or the
plug is a way of making merry jeans on a
regular growing up I wore jeans that
like was kind of fitted but not this
much but this is my first time going as
much City and I did it because I'm a
performer in on stage I need sign like a
performance for me I'm not a basketball
player ongoing stage and sweats in short
so gotta hide the right genes and
Eugene's I come jump around get on the
stage without ripping your pins these
chains right is it ready
no gotta keep one of these for the time
never had the time setup on my watch
cuz it was like you wanna look at man
diamonds but then I keep on looking at
my watch everyday like now I need to
look at the tamil in this damn [ __ ]
crazy petit Phillipe Patek Phillipe
however you want to say I won't call it
same thing different name
I usually got a lot of jewelry on but
today I only came in my tennis chain if
you want to see the rest of my jewelry
go check out the last video I did
collection is crazy he's about to get
crazy
no wait me what is about to be hoodie
seizes win number one collection is
about to go crazy let's go everywhere I
go I gotta keep up the older ones I got
no aluminum almond ham is the best brand
I feel like with no aluminum because I
still got that good smell to it
ya know aluminum in your deodorant you
go Google at home got I ain't no doctor
I'm gonna get it so a lot but I'll give
it to your kids with that 20 percent
aluminum dose it means just cut that out
right now I'm gonna stay out and stay
out the man gotta keep my playstation
with me everywhere I go
2k 1499 potent I ain't even gonna jack
that rating that because they've been
killing me affording a vote I'm damn two
K's one no I got enough fifa believe it
or not I ain't old via but I'm old deep
regular good I'm regular good I love
xbox - I love the graphics I love all
apps but all my friends got PlayStation
so I can't be online with no randoms I
got a name that site familiar so I'll be
online day be like yo that's my mystery
lady
gotta keep that [ __ ] bag on me
y'all know what's in the bag but I got
the bag it's a Louis bag man you're not
I ran through Louis and cuz it goes to
restore my sense she got back up and
worry about what's in it
we're about to surgery we're about your
business
you know every guy I keep my own shout
out to pull my shout out to BIG's about
certainly shot the whole right nation
this is fire a this is Bob wasn't sent
to this is one of my favorites
I don't mind me like a race car type it
study season right now so I got this
deal hoodie don't go over the prorating
I've got the I got the hang of AD
infrared I like what my clothes so
comfortable stick just cuz it's fast she
told me you gotta be can comfortable no
I keep my wallet with me everywhere I go
of course I'm a mean so gotta be as
possible with one of these this remind
me you wanted him to go back Wallace
when I was a kid I always wanted move
your tongue and this was like the main
print for that a pic keep a few calls in
here can't keep that much cash
everywhere I go to the airports have
more than ten thousand they stopped me
through the airport I won't be checking
that cuz I don't want to get stopped if
you say do you have two thousand I'm
gonna act like a guy 9999 is on the
island guard 10,000 a lot of people
don't know but this right here is called
a dump
I keep like five of these on me this is
my last one I got today I'm gonna studio
everyday studios don't got him running
gotta go get one of these these damn
things killing I think Apple is getting
10 times more rich over uses I think
people probably spent more money on
these and phones essentially my last
essential I take with me everywhere it's
not here right now cuz I killed it nice
and peace to the Mises I just killed
maybe I can make a pop up in this video
I keep reaches everywhere I go Reese's
Pieces reach two cups my favorite too
too surreal I'll go crazy now I don't
even like peanut butter that much that's
why I spray the others like the reason
is the combination between that type of
chocolate was that peanut butter
[Music]
crazy with all right that was it it's a
boogie with honey and harbors late with
New York City our New York
that was my centuries Nunez go
[Music]